[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's God.
It's God.
>> In Islam, God, Allah is Allah and Jesus
is a prophet.
>> So even in Catholics and Christians,
Jesus is God.
>> Yeah. Jesus is God.
>> Don't say Allah is not real. Don't say
that.
>> Don't say that.
>> Yeah. We'll talk about it. Hey, hey,
brother, brothers and sisters, I need
you guys do not be a distraction. All
right? Let us handle the conversation.
All right? Cuz it's been going very,
very well. so far.
>> All right.
>> Yeah. Where's the thing? All Christians,
say this. I believe in one God, the
Father Almighty, maker heaven, all
things visible and invisible, and in one
Lord, Jesus Christ, the only begotten
Son of God, begotten of his father
before all worlds, God of God, light of
light, very God of very God, begotten
not made, being of one substance with
the Father, by whom all things were
made. for us men and for our salvation.
He came down from heaven and was
incarnate by the Holy Spirit of the
Virgin Mary and was made man and was
crucified also for us under Pontious
Pilot. He suffered and was he suffered
and was buried. And on the third day he
rose again according to the scriptures
and ascended into heaven and sits at the
right hand of the father. And he will
come again with glory to judge both the
living and the dead whose kingdom will
have no end. And I believe in the Holy
Spirit, the Lord and giver of life, who
proceeds from the father and the son of
>> who with the father and the son together
is worshiped and glorified, who spoke by
the prophets. That is basically almost
the nice creed. All Christians say that
>> in church. So that's what Christians
believe. We believe father, son, and
holy spirit are God.
>> Jesus is
>> Jesus. Jesus is God in Christianity.
Yes.
>> And I think that's your opinion. You're
allowed to. And you we could say the
same thing about our religion. It's like
you're allowed to have whatever religion
you want. That's just like a given I
feel like. But to I mean actually it's
your religion so there's nothing I can
say.
>> So can I ask you a question then about
that? So
>> Jesus said I am the way, the truth and
the life. No one comes to the father
except through me. He did not say you
could have your own religion. He said
you will never get to heaven without me.
That is the Christian claim. That is
what we believe. So we can't go around
saying yeah just have your own religion
when Jesus told us you have to believe
in me to be saved. And that's why we're
out here.
>> Jesus told you that not like not like
there's other people. It's crazy to say
that there's only one religion and in
the end like inshallah when we do pass
like like when we do like we're going to
find that truth out and if that's your
truth that's like I respect that and
that and I have my truth and there's
nothing you could say like oh there
you're not allowed to have a different
religion. That's not real. Like as a
Muslim I have my Christian friends right
here my best friends. I would do
anything for them. They're allowed to
have what whatever religion they want.
They could be anything. I respect it.
But you can't sit here and say there is
only one religion.
>> So
yes, we can.
>> That's your free will.
>> So yeah, here's the difference of
>> the same thing. I could say the same
thing to you and you're not going to
believe me, right?
>> No. No. Because we
>> like debate. There's
>> You believe Jesus is a prophet though,
right?
>> Yes.
>> You believe that when he came, he gave
wisdom and guidance from God.
>> Yeah, I think so.
>> So when he said, "I am the way, the
truth, and the life. No one comes to the
father except through me.
What does that mean? According to you,
>> again, that's in your that's in the
Bible. In the Quran, it says different
things. You can't sit here and say
there's only in your Bible, it says
that, but in mine, it doesn't. That's
just you have to be respectful. You
can't be like, "Oh, there's only one
religion." Cuz I could say the same
thing. That's what the Quran says. The
understand but God is God. Like Allah is
Allah. Like the Quran tells you to see
it.
>> Oh, you want to see where the Quran
says? Yeah. Look, this this is this is
an important verse because what you're
what you're saying.
>> Yeah. So you I I got my own mic. See,
you keep it on them and IP.
>> So So what the Quran says now, the Quran
is really really uh clear with this.
Look at what it says about us.
>> Um I'm going to go to chapter 98. Huh?
>> About Christians.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Chapter 98:6.
>> You like that? You like that?
>> I know that one.
>> All right.
>> So uh verse six here. It says, "Verily
those who disbelieve in the prophet
Muhammad from among the people of the
scripture, Jews and Christians shall
abide in the fire of hell. They are the
worst of creatures." So the Quran and
like you're saying we should respect
each other's religions and stuff like
that. The Quran does not say that. The
Quran tells me
>> as a disbeliever, I'm the worst.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it tell it tells me that I'm
the worst of creatures if I don't
believe in Islam.
>> Yeah, I but I can't I don't control like
the Quran. That's But also in the what?
>> Yeah, but you believe in it. So,
>> yes, I do.
>> You're hanging out with Christians.
>> If you believe in the Quran, you have to
believe we are the worst. Don't respect.
Don't respect us. Go ahead.
>> Also, like that was written.
>> No, just go to Guys. Guys, be quiet.
Brother, I'm going to remove you if you
keep saying something.
>> He said something about the
>> Don't say anything about he said he was
saying like you guys are not wearing
>> Hey, brother. Brothers, brothers, is
that you?
>> It's our choice.
>> I need I need you to be quiet for this.
Okay. We don't We don't want stumbling
blocks. You feel me? Let's preach the
gospel. All right.
>> Oh, I will.
>> Okay.
But also like the Quran was written a
very very very long time ago. In their
eyes, like literally in their eyes, they
thought that that's what they genuinely
thought. Like that's the thing. Like
this is supposed
>> Wait, does it say anything? I have a
question. Like I'm not very educated on
Christianity. Does it say anything in
the Bible that like you if you don't
believe in Jesus and God like you're
going to hell?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> So then why are you making that
statement?
>> Let me let me tell you why. Let me tell
you why. So remember you got you're
saying that in your opinion everybody
should be able to just go their own way
and it's okay it's all good right? I'm
saying as Muslims as Muslims and as
Christians we cannot believe that both
of our religious books says that the way
is very narrow.
>> You have to believe in Islam in order to
get to paradise according to the Bible.
You have to believe in Jesus Christ.
>> I guess we'll see when we die.
>> No. No it's not we'll see when we die.
We can know right now. I'm telling you.
>> We'll see when we die cuz you don't know
anything. the only God.
>> I know you're right. I don't know
anything. God knows. And what's the only
thing we do around here, y'all?
>> We just read.
>> That's it. We just read our scripture.
Look, what I'm saying is, you
>> So, what I'm saying is is that God
revealed himself to us to where we can
know now. We don't have to wait till
judgment day and say, "Well, God, man, I
I thought you was the other thing. I
thought you was Vishnu or I thought you
was Allah or I thought you were Jesus."
No, he made himself clear to us today
and we can know how. If you want to show
know how, I can show you how. I
understand, but our like Allah also said
the exact same thing to us. Like you're
saying you're saying these points, but
it's the exact same thing for us.
>> So guess what what we do is is we test
it. This is what the Bible says. The
Bible
>> You think you could test it?
>> Absolutely. Yes. Okay. Look, look, look.
She said, "Show me." I love it.
>> Let's do it. Okay. So, here's here's
here's some things that the Quran gives
us a way to verify it, right? To know
that it's true. You ready for it?
>> You're saying the Quran's not true? I'm
saying the Quran's not true without a
shadow of a doubt. Okay? And I'm not
being a hypocrite. I'm saying that the
Bible is true, not because I'm a
Christian, but because we have valid
historical and theological reasons to
believe it. The reason why I reject the
Quran is not because I'm a Christian and
it disagrees with me. The reason why I
reject the Quran is because internally
it doesn't make sense. I'm going to show
you how. You ready? Yes.
>> Okay. So, if we go to, for example,
I'm going to show you two important
verses. Okay? Just two.
>> All right. Here's one of my favorite
verses. This is chapter 5 47. It says,
"Let the people of the gospel judge by
what Allah has revealed therein. And
whoever does not judge by what Allah has
revealed, then such people are the
rebellious, right? The disobedient." So
according to this verse, the people who
have the gospel, that's us Christians,
>> we have to use the gospel as our judge.
So whatever disagrees with the B with
the gospel is false. That's what we're
supposed to judge, right? So according
to the Quran, whatever disagrees with
the gospel is false according to us.
According to the gospel, cuz I'm
supposed to judge by the gospel. Make
sense? So the Quran, if it disagrees
with the gospel, I have to judge that
the Quran is false if it contradicts it.
Make sense? Yes.
>> All right. So here's another thing,
barely important. Okay. We're going to
go to chapter 7. This will be the icing
on the cake here. Chapter 7, verse 157.
Right here, it says, "Those who follow
the messenger, the prophet, who can
neither read nor write, whom they find
written with them in the Torah, and the
NGO, the gospel." So, what this verse
says is that we are supposed to be able
to find Muhammad mentioned in the Bible.
I'm supposed to find him in the Torah.
and I'm supposed to find him in the
gospel. If he's not there, then I have
to judge that the Quran is making a
false claim. You see what I'm saying?
>> Yes.
>> So, the Quran is not relying on itself
for its truthfulness. It's relying on my
books. So, I can know that the Quran is
true based on what my book says from the
Quran standpoint. You understand the
point?
>> I have a question. Like, when it says
the Gospel, is it only talking about
yours or ours?
>> Well, wait. It says in surah 7157
their Torah and gospel. It says we can
find him.
>> So Muhammad
>> yeah it's saying
>> what do you mean that you're saying like
I'm not understanding. Sorry.
>> Yes. It's okay. I'll try to break it
down. So what it's saying is is that the
Jews and Christians
the Jews and Christians are supposed to
be able to find Muhammad mentioned in
their scriptures. Okay.
>> So you So in the Bible in the Bible it's
supposed to mention Muhammad.
>> Exactly. Yeah. Exactly.
>> Does it mention?
>> No, no, it doesn't. Now, because of
this, right, the Quran is making a
claim, right? It's making a claim. So,
it's making a claim that I can actually
verify, I can actually check this to see
if it's true. All I got to do is pick up
a Bible and read it. So, if I read the
whole Bible and Muhammad's nowhere
mentioned, he's nowhere mentioned,
described, then therefore the Quran is
making a false claim and therefore it's
not from God.
>> Yeah.
>> Make sense? No, I don't know much about
it. I had to read the Quran and the
Bible to see.
>> Exactly. So, so, so and that's fair,
right? In order for you to know this,
you have to read it for yourself to see.
Okay. I know this guy said that mom is
not in the scriptures, but let me read
it myself, which I implore you to do.
>> Pick up a Bible anytime, go online,
whatever. You got the phone, you can
download the Bible on your app, right?
It's called the Bible app. Easy. Go
through the Bible and see if Muhammad is
mentioned in there. See if you find him
anywhere. You won't. And when you do
that, be honest. Like, be honest. Do I
see Muhammad in here? No. And if he's
not in here, then the Quran's false.
It's making a false claim.
>> So, I don't believe that, though. I
won't believe it. Still,
>> you still won't believe it?
>> Well, it's like I'm not very educated on
that specific stuff, so I can't like
talk about it. You know what I mean?
>> I know, but
>> Well, you can't sit here and deny
people's religion at all.
>> No. No. So, no. This is what we're
talking about, guys. Look, it's it's I
it would be disrespectful of me to just
let you guys like w around here with you
know kumbaya and if I know like if I
know something is false or untrue, it
would be it wouldn't be loving for me to
continue to let you guys believe
something ignorantly, you know, and when
I say ignorantly meaning just not
knowledge of it, you know, not not being
aware of it, okay? Not not as an insult.
So, it's loving of me to bring stuff
bring awareness to certain things for
you. You know what I'm saying? Like if
you guys haven't heard this stuff before
today, right? You guys have heard this
stuff before. And so it's a comment on
me to share it with you. Now, I can't
force it down your throat, but it's upon
you, your duty after this conversation
to go on your own, look into what we've
said today, and to see if it's true or
false. And if it's true, be honest with
it. If it's false, be honest with it.
>> Wait, I have a question. Does it say at
all in the Quran about Jesus or No.
>> Yeah,
>> it does talk about Jesus. Show me that.
>> Yeah, sure. Yeah. So, the Quran talks
about Jesus.
>> Um, we go to chapter
>> I'm not educated on like I'm doing good.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah. You don't have you don't you don't
you don't got to be a scholar to have
these type of conversations. You know,
we just
>> we just we just out here in New York
thug thugging it out. You know what I'm
talking about? You thugging it out. You
you already showed your thugness. She
said, "Well, I will move him." And he's
saying one more thing to me. All right.
So, this is chapter 3:45. Um it says,
"Remember when the angel said, "Oh
Miriam, verily Allah gives you the glad
tidings of a word um from him, his name
will be the Messiah, Jesus, uh the son
of Mary, held in honor in this world and
in the hereafter, and will be one of
those who are near to Allah." And
there's other verses that talk about
Jesus, too.
>> Um now, here's a important part where it
talks about Jesus. Watch this. And this
is the part where we're like, "Ah, come
on, Allah.
This you shouldn't have said this,
Allah. Come on, man. I thought we was
cool for a second." Look. So, this is
chapter 9:30.
It says, "The Jews say Ezra is the son
of Allah. The Christians say the Messiah
is the son of Allah." That is their
saying with their mouths, resembling the
sayings of those who disbelieved a four
time before them. Allah's curse be on
them. How they are deluded away from the
truth. So the Quran is very clear that
Jesus is not his son and whoever says
that Jesus is his son is a cursed and
they are deluded. Right? You see how
strict the Quran is? The Quran is very
strict. You have a different attitude
than Allah does. So he's like, "Hell no,
man. I ain't got no son." Right? He's
straight up. And whoever believes this
is cursed.
>> Jesus says the opposite. Jesus says,
"For God so loved the world that he gave
his only begotten son that whoever
believes in him should not perish but
>> have eternal life." So according this is
this is the gospel. This is the message
of Jesus. This is Jesus saying this.
He's saying I'm the son of God who came
down from heaven, took on flesh.
>> So you just said that you just said he's
a prophet. You said
>> Yeah, he's both. He's both. Yes. Prophet
is someone who speaks on behalf of God.
Jesus came in the flesh and speaks on
behalf of the father who is God.
Therefore, he is
>> he is the son of God and a prophet.
>> You can be both.
>> Yeah. Both. Yeah. You can be both.
Didn't know that.
>> Yeah. If you if you're a spokesman for
God, you're you know you're a prophet.
Now, if you're if you're God himself,
you can come in the flesh and speak on
your own miracle.
>> So God sent Jesus down, but Jesus is
God.
>> Yeah. So you what we have is the
Trinity. So we we don't believe that God
is like so we this is what we believe
that there's one divine essence one
divine infinite essence that we that is
called the divine essence is God right
now God exists as three distinct persons
the father the son and the holy spirit
so the bible describes god as love right
now love requires another person right
love is uh is expressed in affection and
communicated right so because god in his
very essence is love within the very
essence of god God exists a multiplicity
of persons who are communicating in in
that love from eternity's past. So
that's where you have the father who
loves the son who loves the holy spirit
and vice versa. It's a cycle of love.
>> It's like what I said earlier, they are
one substance. Jesus was one substance
with the father. So they are two
persons. The holy spirit is the third
person. They are all one substance but
they are three persons. One god now and
forever yet three persons.
>> Yeah. So when when it comes to God,
especially with this concept, you won't
find anything in creation that you can
think of that's like this, right? You
can't point to something and be like,
"Wow, that's like God." There's we can't
make this up. You know what I'm saying?
Like I wouldn't be smart enough to make
up or complicated enough to like God is
one in three persons. Like what in the
world? Like that makes no for us cuz God
is completely other. So he's unlike his
creation. But so if you can if you can
imagine God, if you can picture him and
compare him, then that's really not God.
But the God the God who's triune, we
can't compare him to anything. So he
fits that bill. Make sense?
>> So yeah, that's also something to
consider as well.
>> So if you guys have another question,
you guys could definitely That's it.
>> Amazing.
>> No. Yeah. Yeah. You guys you guys asked
good questions. You guys are very
humble. I love how inquisitive you guys
are. Like you guys wasn't you guys
didn't argue in emotion. You guys really
thought about these things. So
>> yeah, imagine this. We get a lot. We get
cussed out a lot, but we but we talk
like this. Like we've known each other
for a few weeks now, you know, like we
cool. So, you know, this is how we try
to conduct ourselves. So, um but yeah,
this is what we do. I want to appreciate
you guys for the conversation, man. It
was very nice to meet you guys.
>> Yeah. All right. Have a good have a good
rest of your night. Yeah. Be safe. All
right. Don't punch on nobody.
>> All right. Let's up for them guys.